[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález las cifras
en la región no son alentadoras el
contexto de la pandemia de kobe 19
sumado a otros aspectos de
vulnerabilidad social y de problemas
económicos han dejado a la región de
américa latina y el caribe como una de
las regiones donde más ha aumentado el
hambre y la inseguridad alimentaria
según un informe que fue presentado por
la organización de alimentos y
agricultura de las naciones unidas-
conocida como fao por sus siglas en
inglés veamos rápidamente algunas de las
cifras que da a conocer este informe el
hambre en américa latina' el hambre
aumentó un 30 por ciento es decir 59,7
millones de personas en américa latina
del caribe sufrieron hambre durante el
2020 o 2020 durante el confinamiento en
particular el 41% de la población
mundial está en situación de inseguridad
alimentaria vamos a seguir hablando de
la inseguridad alimentaria justamente ya
lo decía el 41% de la población del
mundo hoy en día está afectada por este
tema la región de américa del sur dentro
de américa latina' es donde más creció
la inseguridad alimentaria de acuerdo
con las cifras presentadas por el
informe aumentó el 24% del 2014 al 2020
julio verdad el representante regional
de la fao se refirió a este tema veamos
cuáles fueron sus palabras si es la
región del mundo que en el período de
pandemia de el 2020 en comparación con
el 2019
empeoró más en términos porcentuales
el problema es que en américa latina lo
que falta no es comida lo que falta es
dinero en muchos bolsillos
es un problema
no es cierto de
insuficientes ingresos para comprar los
alimentos que están ahí primero de estos
niveles de inseguridad alimentaria y de
hambre no nos vamos a salvar
si no se recuperan las economías y no
aumenta el empleo
eso es lo fundamental
operación económica pero con foco en
determinados y eso requiere programas
públicos y desde luego inversión privada
ya no sólo es recuperar la economía en
general sino invertir desde políticas
públicas para que hay esta recuperación
económica y del empleo en aquellos
sectores que son más vulnerables al
hambre a la inseguridad alimentaria
esto espantoso que en américa latina y
el caribe siglo veintiuno
cuatro de cada diez personas que te vas
a cruzar en la calle yendo a tu casa son
personas que no se han alimentado
adecuadamente el día de hoy
adicional al aumento del hambre en
américa latina' este informe también
alerta sobre el aumento en el porcentaje
de población con obesidad y sobrepeso
hace una alerta en particular para los
más jóvenes los menores de edad en
américa latina' están presentando más
cantidad de casos de sobrepeso y
obesidad en nuestros países en américa
latina y también presenta una alerta en
particular sobre como la mujer ha tenido
que sortear a lo largo de estos años o
meses de confinamiento de pandemia esta
situación del hambre es sin duda alguna
una de las grandes perjudicadas de toda
esta situación si lo comparamos con el
porcentaje de hombres en nuestra región
que están padeciendo hambre o que están
en una condición de riesgo de empezará a
padecer hambre en nuestros países para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
israel' ríos castillo él es oficial de
la región regional de nutrición para
américa latina y el caribe de la fao se
encuentra en ciudad de panamá también
está con nosotros michael arts ella es
asesora regional sobre vivir y prosperar
de unicef américa latina y el caribe
ella es irlandesa y también se conecta
con nosotros desde la ciudad de panamá y
en el estudio de france 24 nos acompaña
giovanni reyes él es profesor titular de
la universidad del rosario en la ciudad
de bogotá cuenta con un page de de
economía o un phd en economía para el
desarrollo de la universidad de
pittsburgh en los eeuu ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y sus preguntas lo pueden hacer a través
de las redes sociales la recuerdo
estamos en facebook en instagram y en
twitter no se encuentran como france24
bien bajo s arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios para que ustedes también
sean parte de esta conversación vamos a
comenzar entonces hablando del hambre en
américa latina con israel comencemos que
fue el primer invitado que les presenté
hablemos con él él se encuentra en la
ciudad de panamá israel primero para
comenzar el debate quiero conocer sus
impresiones sobre este informe qué
sensaciones le deja a estas cifras que
no son positivas para la región de
américa latina es la región que más
hambre está padeciendo en el mundo
y muchísimas gracias por la entrevista y
yo creo que es muy importante resaltar
que en este contexto de pandemia pues
las cifras de hambre de subalimentación
y de inseguridad alimentaria golpean con
mayor fuerza porque nos muestra la
vulnerabilidad que tenemos nosotros los
latinoamericanos a ser impactados por
crisis como la que estamos viviendo en
donde 9.1 por ciento de la población en
américa latina y el caribe se clasifica
en condición de hambre son cerca de 60
millones de personas son 14 millones de
personas más que en tan sólo un año el
año de la pandemia se incrementaron a
esta cifra tenemos que tomar en cuenta
también el contexto de la agenda 2030
para el desarrollo sostenible cuyo
objetivo de desarrollo número 2 es
precisamente lograr una américa latina y
el caribe libre de hambre las cifras
pues llegan en un momento crítico en
donde nos alejan aún más de esa meta
anhelada de una región libre de hambre y
de inseguridad alimentaria además de los
otros objetivos pobreza disminución de
la brecha digital además de género en
fin una serie de indicadores que nos
alejan de este anhelado desarrollo
sostenible pero cada vez se van
acumulando más deudas pendientes con las
sociedades en américa latina' saludo a
mike martz ella se encuentra en ciudad
de panamá buenas noches may que sus
impresiones sobre este informe qué
sensación le deja usted la situación que
se está presentando en américa latina'
con estas cifras
sí muchas gracias también por pues la
entrevista en sí no nos preocupa
bastante como mi colega israel dijo el
número de personas que estás sufriendo
de hambre está aumentando y aumento por
la situación de la pandemia y esto
obviamente específicamente impacta a los
niños y niñas y lo que nosotros estamos
a ver que también se está describiendo
en el mismo reporte es que las cifras de
desnutrición también
están como se llaman o no están
mejorando como tal lo que sí está
mejorando es la prevalencia del retraso
en el crecimiento pero la velocidad está
disminuyendo en los últimos años
entonces en este momento tenemos 5.8
millones de niños que son que tienen
este retraso en el crecimiento y lo que
nos preocupa bastante chame es el
aumento en el sobrepeso que ahora
tenemos casi 4 millones de niños menores
de 5 años el 5 el 7.5 por ciento de
niños que tienen el sobrepeso y esto
parece ser tal vez una contradicción con
la situación del hambre pero una cosa
que nos preocupa es la calidad de la
dieta y nosotros hablamos con niños y
niñas y adolescentes de 3 al 29 años de
edad en 2 años 2020 y 2021 y lo que nos
dijeron es que la respuesta a estas
familias a sus familias les cuesta del
expuesto digamos durante la pandemia les
costó más de conseguir alimentos
saludables entonces esto es una
situación que nos preocupa mucho que más
de la mitad de los niños y niñas en esos
dos años no consiguieron alimentos
saludables porque no tienen dinero
suficiente y también obviamente el miedo
al hobby pero si nos preocupa bastante
le vamos a
comentar sobre la obesidad y sobre la
inseguridad alimentaria y sobre el caso
de las mujeres en particular lo vamos a
desarrollar más adelante en el programa
salud aquí en el estudio de france 24 a
giovanni reyes en giovani bienvenido y
sus impresiones de este informe lo que
la sensación que le deja y lo que le
dicen estas cifras de la lucha contra la
pobreza contra el hambre en américa
latina muchas gracias muchas gracias por
la invitación por la entrevista santiago
ya france24 si al margen ya lo han dicho
los expositores que me antecedieron al
margen de las cifras que son terribles
que son absolutamente terribles
yo quisiera subrayar dos cosas si me
permite la primera es que esto es una
muestra de la disfuncionalidad la
disfuncionalidad de los sistemas
económicos y sociales la gran
vulnerabilidad que tenemos la región
crece y lame y la región puede mejorar
en términos relativos con la cuestión
digamos macroeconómica pero la gente del
común la gran mayoría hay sectores
vulnerables que son presa digamos de
esta de esta situación entonces primero
el lo que quisiera subrayar es la
vulnerabilidad y la disfuncionalidad de
los sistemas como lo tenemos y en
segundo lugar creo yo que también unido
a eso está la debilidad institucional
que tenemos la debilidad institucional
que no protege de esta situación de los
alimentos que serían derechos
esencialmente de la población entonces
tenemos sistemas que concentran los
beneficios del crecimiento económico
cuando lo tenemos pero también excluyen
a muchas de los de los sectores de por
sí ya vulnerables yo dejaría esas dos
impresiones esa vulnerabilidad que
tenemos y la disfuncionalidad que
estamos manifestando sobre todo santiago
el año pasado que sabemos que con
producto de la pandemia tuvimos que
enfrentar dos choques simultáneos
choques de oferta y choques de demanda
en nuestros sistemas productivos
tomando en cuenta esa vulnerabilidad que
usted menciona y esa disfuncionalidad
aquí en la región está entonces américa
latina' perdiendo esta lucha contra el
hambre porque veíamos como usted lo
decía una región que venía creciendo la
mayoría de los países venían creciendo
económicamente hasta que empezó el
confinamiento y la pandemia del cobi 19
eso nos lleva a otra conclusión y es que
seguimos con este fantasma de la
desigualdad que los países están
creciendo pero son uno de los que se
están enriqueciendo no todos en los
países está américa latina' perdiendo la
lucha contra el hambre yo creo que en
este momento si santiago depende de los
periodos de tiempo que nosotros
analizamos por ejemplo la década de los
80 una década perdida como dice la cepal
entonces tuvimos retrocesos pero hay
digamos
una ligera mejora también en lo social
durante los noventas durante los años la
primera década de este siglo todos
sabemos que de 2003 aproximadamente a
2014 hubo un precio relativamente alto
de las exportaciones del portafolio de
exportación de américa latina y eso
ayudó a muchos de los regímenes pero
luego hubo una tendencia al
estancamiento y desde luego con la
pandemia hay un retroceso más que
evidente claro le pregunto a mal que en
la ciudad de panamá sobre qué cambios
deberían darse entonces a nivel
estructural porque el tema del hambre no
es un tema nuevo en la región de esto
podría decir que es un repunte debido a
la pandemia del confinamiento ya la
crisis económica que ha desatado la
crisis sanitaria a nivel global pero el
hambre ha estado presente en américa
latina' largo de muchas décadas que
cambios estructurales entonces valdría
la pena hacer para empezar a combatirlo
desde otro ángulo porque tal parece que
lo que hemos hecho no ha funcionado
y muchas gracias este es un tema muy
importante lo que es muy importante es
priorizar los grupos más vulnerables y
lo que dice este reporte es que son las
mujeres y son los grupos indígenas y los
grupos afrodescendientes entonces
priorizar a proteger estos grupos más
vulnerables y también los grupos
marginalizados en las áreas rurales pero
también las áreas urbanas también lo que
es muy importante invertir en sistemas
de protección social y también ver los
demás sistemas del sistema alimentario
el sistema de salud el sistema de
educación agua y saneamiento todos los
sistemas tienen que trabajar juntos y
necesitamos políticas también que
protegen el acceso a los alimentos
saludables y también sistemas que pueden
apoyar a las familias de hacer de
escoger los alimentos más saludables
entonces hay políticas como el
etiquetado frontal y a veces las medidas
de impuestos para por ejemplo las aguas
las las bebidas azucaradas entonces
necesitamos un sistema de política que
protejan el acceso y que protejan el
acceso a los alimentos saludables y que
toman en cuenta las vulnerabilidades y
bert también en todos los sistemas de
salud de protección de edificación y de
agua esto no tiene que trabajar juntas
bueno todo esto tiene que trabajar junto
y esto tiene que tener un inicio y
alguien que lo impulse israel quien
puede impulsar esto los líderes sociales
los grupos de ciudadanos asociaciones de
médicas de pacientes de no sé cuál
sector de la sociedad deba impulsar esto
ante las autoridades porque desde las
autoridades no hay esa iniciativa desde
donde se puede impulsar
y en efecto yo creo que mike y ha
apuntado a algunas de las respuestas más
relevantes yo creo que el enfoque del
sistema alimentario da un sentido a qué
actores son los que se convocan para la
solución de estos problemas el problema
del hambre como bien ha mencionado es un
problema que tiene raíces profundas y
por lo tanto solucionarlo requerirá el
aporte de todos los sectores el sector
privado un firme compromiso hacia la
transformación de sistemas alimentarios
que favorezcan la alimentación saludable
por supuesto los estados a través de la
garantía del derecho humano a la
alimentación adecuada y de los derechos
fundamentales sobre todo en aquellos
grupos de mayor vulnerabilidad de las
mujeres los niños pequeños los contextos
indígenas y los grupos afrodescendientes
las políticas de protección social y las
diferentes políticas sectoriales el
sector productivo el sector salud yo
creo que es un llamado a la acción de
todos los sectores a unir esos esfuerzos
para combatir el hambre y lograr la
anhelada meta del desarrollo sostenible
importante también contribución desde
academia tenemos una participación
relevante sobre todo para visibilizar a
los rostros la cara de las personas que
están en esta condición de hambre de
mayor vulnerabilidad y la academia tiene
un rol fundamental en encontrar esas
soluciones más audaces más innovadoras
las naciones unidas por supuesto este
año 2021 incluso fue antes de la
pandemia que se estableció como el año
para la cumbre de los sistemas
alimentarios para precisamente hacer
esto cuáles son las medidas más
innovadoras más efectivas para lograr un
planeta con libre de hambre y con mayor
sostenibilidad es esta transformación de
los sistemas de alimentarios para dar
respuesta al problema de hambre que hoy
día enfrentamos israel voy a continuar
con usted allí conectado al nacional de
panamá quiero detenerme en tres países
en particular de nuestra región que son
casos críticos muy preocupantes
venezuela nicaragua y haití cómo está la
situación en estos países cómo evaluaban
ustedes lo que está sucediendo allí y
luego del paso maike para hablar de
otros países el que me llamaron la
atención de este listado
salieron allí en como destacados porque
no les está yendo muy bien entonces
comencemos por estos 3 haití venezuela y
nicaragua
y en efecto tú lo acabas de mencionar
los países con con mayor prevalencia de
alimentación o el indicador hambre yo
creo que ahí es importante pero seguir
trabajando con esta agenda de desarrollo
la cooperación internacional es
fundamental es fortaleciendo la sistema
productivo desde la fao estamos apoyando
diversos proyectos vinculados con la
producción de alimentos con la
agricultura familiar con la favorecer el
acceso a los mercados de pequeños
productores sobre todo a través de
mercados institucionales como lo serían
la alimentación escolar uno de los
grandes ejemplos que desde la región
estamos mostrando es cómo hacer que los
pequeños productores de alimentos que
tienen excedentes en la producción
puedan alcanzar cierto grado de calidad
en sus productos y ofertarlos a
programas de adquisición de alimentos
como los programas de alimentación
escolar u otros programas sociales que
adquieren alimentos yo creo que es una
transformación que se requiere tomar
desde el nivel de políticas públicas
desde el
temas sectoriales en ministerios de
agricultura y también en los demás
sectores que adquieren alimentos ya le
voy a dar la palabra a giovanni quiero
preguntarle a michael sobre tres países
también en particular que son los
llamados triángulo del norte que son el
salvador guatemala y honduras allí
la inseguridad alimentaria afecta a casi
el 50 por ciento de la población es
también países que están en alerta
también preocupa obviamente lo que está
sucediendo allí hay riesgo de que estos
países caigan en casos como el de
nicaragua honduras venezuela haití donde
la producción y el aparato económico no
es suficiente para garantizar la
alimentación de los ciudadanos como lo
ve usted
sí
hay muchos riesgos para la situación de
empeorar entonces lo que es importante
es monitorear cómo va la salud y la
nutrición de los niños y niñas eso lo
hacemos también es importante donde hay
medidas de protección social de
fortalecer estas medidas y también
apoyar a las propias familias y las
comunidades por ejemplo apoyar a las
madres con la lactancia materna y
proteger la lactancia materna en todos
los sitios
y también apoyar a las familias de cómo
escoger los alimentos más saludables y
cuando se estamos monitoreando los niños
y se ve que hay niños con desnutrición
también es importante formar el
tratamiento para que mejoren y al mismo
tiempo apoyar a las familias para esta
situación no recurre una vez más
maika y otros tres países perú argentina
y ecuador se destacan en este listado
porque ha crecido por tensión
porcentualmente la inseguridad
alimentaria en el último par de años en
estos países en qué situación están es
preocupante es de estar alerta en qué en
qué escenario están estos tres países
si es preocupante si siempre cuando hay
un empeoramiento de la situación y
también lo que es importante es ver la
desigualdad digamos dentro de un país
porque siempre muchas veces el promedio
de desnutrición por ejemplo desde la
situación de nutrición de los niños el
promedio puede ser bueno pero tenemos
que ver los grupos indígenas que ya
mencionamos a los grupos
afrodescendientes o las familias con con
madres como a jefes de hogar para ver
cuáles son las inequidades y focalizar
los esfuerzos en estas familias mismas
que son los más vulnerables
giovanni no me he olvidado de ustedes
sino que quería dejarlo para el final
para que habláramos en macro de la
región de estos nueve países que
mencioné cómo son los escenarios
económicos en los que están estos países
y cómo son esos escenarios del aparato
productor de estas naciones que no están
garantizando esta la alimentación básica
de los ciudadanos en qué situación están
estos países a nivel económico y
político sin ese instante un mire el
problema fundamental aquí sería digamos
dos a dos niveles un nivel sería el
nivel dentro de los países que es lo que
decía la colega de
enervantes entonces es necesario que las
políticas públicas estén focalizadas
pero esas políticas públicas deben
entenderse como una política de
apalancamiento es decir una ayuda para
la autoayuda de las poblaciones porque
el principal reto que tenemos es la
sostenibilidad entonces todos estamos de
acuerdo en dar una situación de ayuda
sin retribución cuando es una ayuda
humanitaria de emergencia y eso es
totalmente imprescindible estamos
hablando de que el alimento es un
derecho humano etcétera etcétera pero
tenemos que ver la sostenibilidad
entonces como ya decía como los colegas
decían algunas políticas que sean
discriminadas es decir que sean
equitativas la equidad no se traduce en
igualdad la equidad sería el trato justo
de las diferencias vamos a atender a
quienes más lo necesitan eso sería
dentro de los países ahora a nivel de
toda la región yo creo que todos estamos
claros en que hay dos grandes grupos
extremos hay un grupo que funcionalmente
las tiene un desempeño muy aceptable yo
diría uruguay costa rica trinidad tobago
y hasta cierto punto chile muy bien y
algunas regiones de argentina pero luego
tenemos en el otro extremo los más los
países con mas disfuncionalidad haití
lamentablemente la crisis en venezuela
quien lo dijera la potencia petrolera de
la región entonces haití venezuela
nicaragua como se indicaba pero también
honduras guatemala hasta cierto punto
salvador entonces son sociedades que
tienen más retos también bolivia y hasta
cierto punto guyana son sociedades que
tienen más retos y por lo tanto la
institucionalidad santiago es muy
importante pero yo subrayaría que a
partir de ese entramado tal vez el
problema no es que no sepamos qué hacer
tenemos que fortalecer la
institucionalidad tenemos que ver cómo
sacamos recursos pero aquí vienen dos
problemas esenciales voluntad política
voluntad política yo quisiera subrayar
eso los recursos se consiguen pero es
necesario tener una voluntad política
sostenida que cuando venga un gobierno
no destruya digamos lo que ha hecho el
anterior sino una voluntad política que
se concrete en iniciativas de estado más
que de gobiernos uno y segundo el
problema de la corrupción tenemos muchos
recursos
recuerdo una pancarta de una
manifestación en guatemala hace como
cuatro años que decía no nos no nos
hacen falta recursos lo que nos sobran
son ladrones
a la pancarta entonces la lucha contra
la corrupción y la voluntad política
decidida de esto que es una tragedia
humana humana que estamos enfrentando
además que todavía no hemos visto la
magnitud económica de lo que puede
llegar a ser la pandemia kobe 19 porque
no sabemos cuánto va a durar extra
entonces no sabemos cuánto tiempo más
vamos a estar con problemas económicos
en estos países y a lo mejor estas
cifras pueden empezar a crecer si esto
se mantiene unos cuantos años más
giovanni continuó con usted
preguntándole qué hay de los organismos
internacionales porque no hay acción o
por lo menos uno no ve o no evidencia
más allá de estos reportes de estas de
estas cifras que publican no hay nadie
que digamos apriete las tuercas a los
gobiernos para decirles entendemos que
están en una crisis sanitaria entendemos
que hay unas necesidades económicas pero
la población tiene hambre y necesitan
comer y hay que alimentarlos de santiago
si esa es una pregunta muy importante
muy importante por lo menos los
organismos internacionales y naciones
unidas luchan mucho con eso nos está
dando cifras nos actualiza cifras eso es
imprescindible es un avance pero no es
suficiente es un avance pero no es todo
lo que necesitamos entonces el problema
es que los organismos internacionales
son constituidos por los gobiernos
naciones unidas- es una entidad que está
conformada por los gobiernos naciones
unidas al final responde a la voluntad
política colectiva de esos gobiernos
naciones unidas- y en sus diferentes
agencias sus 44 programas trabaja para
los gobiernos pero necesita de la
voluntad política de las instituciones
que legítimamente fueron electas para
llevar a cabo esto y el último factor
que quisiera mencionar si me permite
rápidamente santiago el asunto de la
deuda la deuda ha trepado yo puedo
decirle creo que hice bien los cálculos
que cada cinco años toda américa latina
está pagando en servicio de la deuda lo
que sería el equivalente a un plan
marshall que eeuu dedicó para europa
luego de la segunda guerra mundial ahí
tenemos un reto de negociación de la un
reto de ver la sostenibilidad de
nuestros recursos financieros son cifras
y números de grande de muchos ceros
giovanni digámoslo así mai que pasemos a
hablar del tema de las mujeres quiero
que veamos estas cifras que hemos
extraído justamente de este informe las
mujeres experimentaron más inseguridad
alimentaria que los hombres a lo largo
de estos años de meses de pandemia kobe
1940 y 1.8 por ciento de las mujeres han
experimentado inseguridad alimentaria
esta es una cifra superior a la de los
hombres que alcanza el 32 2% que también
es una cifra muy alta
mike e impresiones sobre el papel de la
mujer lo que están viviendo con esta
inseguridad alimentaria y esta
problemática y esta crisis digámoslo así
y que nos alerta este informe porque las
cifras son muy altas para lo que ha
vivido la mujer a lo largo de estos
meses
sí sí este es un tema muy importante y
también lo que también el reporte dice
que es la anemia en mujeres en edad
reproductiva era el 17 por ciento
entonces también
es una cifra bastante preocupante
entonces también lo que vimos durante la
pandemia es lo que se llama la actriz es
de los dos cuidados porque son las
mujeres muchas mujeres y ya no pueden ir
a su trabajo que están trabajando desde
la casa o que perdieron su casa y que
también tienen los niños que no pueden
ir a la escuela tienen que cuidar de los
niños y tienen que comprar los alimentos
y tienen que preparar los alimentos
entonces esto se vuelve en un ciclo
vicioso es de esto para que en que
entonces que es muy difícil para las
mujeres y para también para los niños
porque esas mujeres tienen que hacer
todo no entonces pero ya perdieron su
trabajo hoy están en una situación de
que tienen que trabajar desde la casa y
cuidar los niños y cuidar de los
alimentos entonces esto vuelve a ellas
también con un aumento en la
desnutrición o en la anemia la anemia y
también vimos que si éste la diferencia
en la inseguridad alimentaria y si es es
muy preocupante porque muchas veces son
estas mujeres que quieren que cuidar de
la familia entonces eso también pone en
peligro el desarrollo
de los propios niños
entonces si es algo que nos preocupa
bastante
israel ya vamos llegando a la recta
final del programa quiero que hablemos
del tema de la obesidad y la obesidad
infantiles son son cifras que también me
llamaron mucho la atención
vamos a presentar algunas hay que
recordar que el sobrepeso y la obesidad
son formas de malnutrición las cifras de
obesidad infantil en nuestro continente
son muy altas en américa del sur se
registra que la mayor prevalencia de
sobrepeso infantil está en la región de
américa del sur con el 8,2 por ciento en
el caribe tiene una prevalencia del 66
por ciento y en américa central del 63
por ciento son cifras muy altas también
en qué hacer cómo estamos nutriendo a
nuestros menores de edad cuál es la
calidad de la dieta que les estamos
dando que se están presentando esas
cifras sobre todo en américa del sur son
alarmantes
en efecto la obesidad definida
propiamente por la organización mundial
de la salud como esa acumulación
excesiva de tejido graso que implica
riesgo para la salud es uno de los
principales factores de riesgo para el
desarrollo en edad adulta de
enfermedades crónicas no transmisibles
como la diabetes como la hipertensión
como los problemas cardiovasculares e
incluso varios tipos de cáncer de hecho
antes de la pandemia por kobe 19 las
principales causas de muerte estaban muy
vinculadas con la obesidad
evaluar las cifras en niños menores de 5
años es preocupante debido al futuro que
esto les acarrea en la vida adulta y en
la edad escolar y adolescentes las
cifras en escolares y adolescentes
alcanzan al 20 y hasta el 40 por ciento
de la población con obesidad y con
sobrepeso en adultos es alarmante más
del 40 por ciento de los adultos o más
bien dicho de 262 millones de adultos
están con sobrepeso y 106 millones de
adultos están con obesidad
y separamos o comparamos entre hombres y
mujeres lamentablemente nuevamente el
ser mujer implica un mayor riesgo
también para la obesidad como lo ha sido
para la inseguridad alimentaria
encontramos también una relación muy
estrecha entre la inseguridad
alimentaria y la obesidad debido a que
por falta de dinero o recursos las
familias optan por dietas de menor
calidad altas en
azúcares altas en alimentos no
saludables que condicionan la obesidad
otro de los indicadores que el reporte
panorama de la seguridad alimentaria y
la nutrición en américa latina y el
caribe para este año hace es el elevado
costo que tienen las dietas saludables
definidas como aquellos patrones
alimentarios que incluyen de todos los
grupos de alimentos frutas vegetales
hortalizas
pescados lácteos bajos en grasa para 113
millones de latinoamericanos es
imposible pagar el costo de una dieta
saludable lo que hace es y opten por
dietas menos saludables ricas en
alimentos como bebidas azucaradas o
alimentos altos en alguien a su azúcar y
eso está iniciando desde edades muy
temprana y condiciona enfermedades
crónicas como ya lo he mencionado y sólo
para finalizar la cob y nos ha mostrado
que la obesidad es uno de los factores
de riesgo para hospitalización por kobe
para requerir ventilación mecánica e
incluso las personas con obesidad son
las que más fallecen debido a una
infección por todd y por lo tanto es de
preocupación pero la obesidad acarrea un
montón de problemas de salud no
solamente en el contexto del cobach sino
en líneas generales michael ya estoy en
la parte final del programa
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que
necesitamos que siga produciéndose aquí
en adelante para poder ver cambios
sustanciales para que este panorama no
sea el mismo en unos años y que no
tengamos a la obesidad como una pandemia
también en nuestra región donde nuestra
población esté mal alimentada cuáles
serían sus conclusiones
sí muchas gracias lo que es muy
importante es
escuchar también a los niños niñas y
adolescentes porque también ellos mismos
tienen sugerencias de cómo mejorar la
situación y nosotros lo vimos cuando
hicimos un conteo con niños y niñas y
adolescentes entonces es muy importante
también tener políticas públicas
políticas de protección social políticas
que estimulan el uso y que lo hacen y
que dan la información en dos políticas
públicas por ejemplo sobre el etiquetado
políticas públicas sobre impuestos en
las bebidas azucaradas y otros alimentos
no saludables entonces y también dar
información a las familias claro
unidades sobre la dieta saludable
en el estudio de france 24 su conclusión
sobre esta problemática que hacer que
viene para el futuro santiago yo creo
que el futuro es incierto y puede ser
con una tendencia negativa dado el
dinamismo y la mayor eficacia o la
capacidad de reinventarse que estamos
viendo en el virus entonces la
perspectiva no es de más alentadora y
tenemos que estar gracias a dios ya los
científicos tenemos las vacunas entonces
tenemos que proceder de esa manera
entonces es un punto pero el otro punto
del hambre es que es un indicador
estamos teniendo una señal que responde
a otros a otra problemática más fuerte
que está asociada al desempleo y a la
pobreza entonces para eso lo que
necesitamos creo yo en términos
generales lo que quisiera subrayar esto
uno la voluntad política sostenida para
hacer de los programas de la lucha
contra el hambre algo
insisto sostenido segundo la situación
de los recursos a partir de la
corrupción de renegociación de la deuda
y de los sistemas fiscales y yo creo que
de esta manera con políticas focalizadas
podemos avanzar con prioridad nuestra
giovanni a mike que israel les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis de este
informe de la fao sobre el hambre en
américa latina' les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros sigan dejando todos
sus comentarios y sigan viendo france24
[Música]